لذلك أخذنا قضية الضم
من الجدول
التي اشتريناها للوقت ولن أقول
إن هذا
إلى الأبد ولكنه حقًا
يمنحنا الوقت لأنه بخلاف ذلك
سيكون حل الدولتين على ما
يرام لذلك هذا هو  حيث ما أريد أن
أسألك عنه لقد اشتريت الوقت من
أجل ماذا لأنك على حق
، يبدو أن حل الدولتين
قد مات وأنك قلت أيضًا
شيئًا يتفق معه الآخرون
وهو الابتعاد عن التعامل مع
إسرائيل العربية  لم تجلب لك الدول
الكثير ولكن السؤال هو
ماذا ستفعل الآن وأنت على الطاولة
لأن القيادة الفلسطينية
وصفت هذا بالخيانة وكما تعلم
جيدًا لم يكن موقف الدوري العربي
صفقات منفصلة ما لم يكن هناك اتفاق
بين  إسرائيل والفلسطينيون ،
لذلك يقول الفلسطينيون إنهم ليس لديهم أي فكرة عن
أنهم أصيبوا بالصدمة ولم يعرفوا
عن هذه الصفقة ،
لذلك لم تخبرهم الآن بما يمكنك
فعله لاستخدام نفوذك
على الطاولة لإعادة المشاركة
وإنشاء عملية  هذا أماه  أعيد إحياء
فكرة حل الدولتين ،
حسناً مسيحي هنا ، يجب أن أؤكد
أنه كما قال جاريد كوشنر ، لم نخبر
أحداً أن جميع اتصالاتنا
مع أصدقائنا العرب
وشركائنا الاستراتيجيين كانت فعلاً
بعد إعلان الصفقة
حتى نتمكن
من القيام بذلك.  تأكد من
عدم وجود تسريب لذلك هذا شيء
قررنا أنه
ضروري للصفقة الآن
بالطبع
الفكرة كلها أننا
نحث القيادة الفلسطينية على
أه للاستفادة من هذه الميزة أعني أن
الإمارات العربية المتحدة
ليست واحدة  من شأنها أن
تجري المفاوضات بالفعل ، لكننا
نحث الفلسطينيين
على البقاء على اتصال بالأوقات الصعبة واليأس
هنا ، فهم في كل مكان من حولنا ،
لكن هذه كانت حالة
الشرق الأوسط طوال هذه
السنوات وبالنسبة لنا كنا متسقين معها
رسالتنا وأعتقد أنه من المهم هنا أننا
كنا داعمين تقليديين
وتاريخيين للفلسطينيين
وأعتقد أننا رأينا فرصة هنا
حيث استفدنا من  قضية
التطبيع ورغبة إسرائيل
في التطبيع مع أحد أكبر
الاقتصادات
العربية وقالوا حسنًا إننا سنفعل ذلك ولكن
ما نحتاجه في المقابل
هو هذا التعليق ونفهم
كما قلت أن هذا التعليق
سيشتري مساحة ستشتري  وقتنا
وأعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى
حث جميع الفلسطينيين على الانخراط إذا
نظرت حقًا
إلى الردود التي نسمعها
من الاتحاد الأوروبي من العواصم الأوروبية من
كل شخص كان داعمًا تقليديًا
للمفاوضات وحل الدولتين ،
الجميع منتشي  حول
إزالة هذا من على الطاولة
والقدرة على العودة
والمشاركة وأعتقد أن حثنا على
الفلسطينيين
هو اغتنام هذه الفرصة
وعدم خسارتها لأن تاريخنا
في المنطقة هو تاريخ من الفرص الضائعة